Sean Spicer yesterday blamed the Obama
administration for not doing more to
express their concerns about disgraced
National Security Advisor Michael Flynn
which was bewildering to put it lightly
NBC News reported yesterday as I told
you earlier in the show that President
Obama had specifically warned then
president-elect Donald Trump about
Michael Flynn in a November meeting okay
what we did that earlier I'm not going
to redo that part of the story Sean
Spicer did his daily press briefing
yesterday and said basically that the
warning is because Obama just wasn't a
fan of Michael Flynn and said hey we
should really be looking at the Obama
administration because they renewed
Flynn's security clearance let's take a
look at this video of Sean Spicer
completely unhinged
well I the president doesn't disclose
details of meetings that he has which in
this case was a hour-long meeting but
it's true that the president made it
President Obama made it known that he
wasn't exactly a fan of general Flynn's
which is frankly shouldn't come as a
surprise to anyone that given that
general Flynn had worked for President
Obama was an outspoken critic of
President Obama's shortcomings
specifically as it related to his lack
of strategy confronting Isis and other
threats around that were facing America
so the question that you have to ask
yourself really is if President Obama
was truly concerned about general Flynn
why didn't he suspend general Flynn
security clearance which they had just
really err additionally why did the
Obama administration let Flynn go to
Russia for a paid speaking engagements
even fee there were steps that they
could have taken that if that was truly
a concern more than just a person that
didn't had that blood but but Obama
renewed Flynn's security clearance so
yeah this is bogus Michael Flynn had
already been fired they can try to fired
individuals can still try to hold on to
clearances and those are done by the
agency they used to work for influence
cases the DIA spicer paints it like
Obama went into a room and said Michael
Flynn let's renew his security clearance
it's a totally different and unrelated
process Pat
the one that you go through to become
national security adviser that was a
routine matter for the DIA defense
intelligence agency way back when it's
not Obama saying let's do this or that
and it's stunning that he's even
bringing it up because it's been
debunked so many times you know
President Truman used to have a sign on
his desk that read the buck stops here
for trumpets hey don't look at me I mean
go to Steve Bannon first go to Dora
Kushner first and if all else fails I'll
just blame Obama we'll go to the last
president if all else fails a tweet from
the New York Times's Peter Baker summed
up pretty nicely quote new presidents
often blame predecessors for various
things Trump may be first to blame his
National Security Advisor on his
predecessor Obama fired Flynn but it's
Obama's fault that Trump hired him even
though we know that he warned him it's
not computing yeah I mean Republicans
used to attack Obama for blaming too
much on george w bush yeah but Obama's
attacks had a lot to do with the
circumstances that he found himself in
like the two wars and the recession yeah
Trump is blaming Obama for actions that
he himself took and speiser actually
said that Obama didn't take proactive
steps to deny Michael Flynn security
clearance besides the fact that he fired
him and that the riah prove all of that
clearance had nothing to do with Obama
this is genuinely embarrassing why
didn't obey awarness harder is basically
the question Obama fired him then Obama
warned camp about him then Sally Yates
warned the White House about him then
Sally Yates warned the White House about
Flynn again what more could they
possibly have done maybe Obama should
have had Flynn murdered to really
prevent Trump from being able to hire
him I mean how far are we going to take
this I mean so much of this stuff was
classified at the time and it's not
something that you would mention in a
public setting you know so that's pretty
much all they could do it's gone into
twilight zone territory it truly has